hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 17 of my 1H hour flipping
challenge today we are going to be
flipping recommended items by G tracker
only uh for 1 hour so we're going to see
how this works uh what we're going to be
mainly doing is using the high highest
margin tab in the G tracker website uh
which a link will be in the description
for that if you didn't see my other
video it's just a cool little uh
tracking website that has a bunch of
free features a couple of the ones I'm
going to use are paid uh but for the
most part just use it H like you would
RS buddy and yeah anyway let's jump into
it okay guys we're about to get started
we have 1 hour on the clock we have 40
mil in our
inventory let's get started okay so what
we are going to be doing is we're going
to be going to G tracker so let's see if
we can get that in frame and we're going
to mostly be using this highest
margin as well as we might use the high
volume items tab but for now we're going
to use that flip finder for the highest
margin and so what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be filtering the
items uh so I already put a filter in
here we'll start with h 10 mil
Max and we want items that are actually
buying and selling so at least uh 10
buying quantity minimum and 10 quantity
selling minimum we don't have to set
maximums cuz who
cares and uh yeah uh we'll just quickly
reload
that okay so it's recommending the heavy
ballista as well as the uning heavy
ballista uh cuz they do have a buy quite
a high buy limit so it does trade quite
a lot you can see daily has 800 900
which is pretty good let's try 3520
352k uh we'll do just
one for now cuz we're going to try a
couple different items to D actually no
we'll do more than one wow we already
got a heavy ballista um so okay we'll
pop that in for 35 I'll try 35
70k cuz we got a lot of time but that is
a nice 50k prop right there very easy to
find it honestly wow okay we sold it for
um okay we might want to bump that up a
little bit uh the serpent time Helm uh
we could do that so looking like
2539 it's
recommending I put it in for
2543 2526 or something and we'll do
three of
these and maybe two for
now and uh okay we got a serent Time
Helm actually uh so we'll pop in below
for it's
recommending 25
60k um which isn't yeah seems to be in
line with the um activate trade price so
25 60k would be about 23k in profit so
not awful
armadil chain
skirt uh which is going to be 14377 in
the actively trade price
uh but we'll just put
14300 14300 K and just one for
sure okay so we have bought another
heavy ballista another heavy ballister
uh so we'll pop those in here
for uh
3570k I've got a serpentine Visage sold
so that's
27k um and yeah we're waiting for that
one to buy again yeah an offering for
Wizard boot
script uh so it's saying actively trade
price at 440 uh the last offer
completed was recently and 389 or
400 and just do three of those you know
never
know um okay we actually flipped another
heavy ballista pretty nice there that's
another 45k profit now the serpent time
Helm actually all bought but we're
selling for 2560 uh which is still
pretty nice BR
saber
um what do people use this for again
actually a pretty decently high margin
on it I think we just check the brine
saber here um okay we actually got a
couple important things but first let's
just pop into Bri saber cuz this looks
like a kind of reasonable item I we're
just going to check the margin screw
it
261 and uh inter
interesting okay 226 okay we'll
definitely do this BR saber okay so we
have a armal chain skirt bought so we're
going to try to flip that for hopefully
like at least a 70k profit oh did I
[__] that up no I
didn't okay so I instantly sold it for
14378 okay and now we can move on to the
heavy ballistas uh so we're still
getting a decent margin there sold off
two bought another one um do two more I
guess and um we sold a Ser Helm which is
pretty nice I'm not buying too many of
those yet and we got some wizard boots
so I have no clue what I'm actually
looking for in The Wizard boots we just
put a random price in pretty well okay
uh we got another heavy ballista sold
already um I don't know the limit I'm
just assuming the limit's eight but I'm
not 100% sure so we're going to keep
trying to buy them um we'll put the
offer in for one now uh cuz we're
approaching the limit most likely okay
we sold the two serpent time
Helms uh oh I guess we had one left to
sell okay I'm actually going to try this
ult necklace it has a limit of five I
think so it's not High um but they trade
a lot it's not a terribly expensive item
either um so you can see there's one
tons Trad in this last little bit here
we're going to have to kind of guess
quite heavily what the margin is cuz
it's going be pretty close it's saying I
should buy them for 700 and I think
that's what I'm going to try
cult
necklace B for 700k on the dot and we'll
just do five cuz as soon as we get the
margin they should sell quite
quickly and there we go um we got some
heavy ballistas sold as
well uh so 35 to5 still getting a good
margin on the ballista so we're up to
the point where we've sold all the heavy
ballistas we'll leave this in a little
longer but we may have gotten to the
point where we have actually just
flipped as many as we can we got another
cult necklace so that's nice put it in
for maybe it's even less who knows we'll
put in for 712 scit it's recommending I
buy them
for
13497 so let's try
499k and we bought another SHP time Helm
now I cannot remember how many of these
we fli and we got another two ult
necklaces which which is pretty cool pop
those in over here got 712 is still the
limit are the margin sure and we have a
ant dragon fire Shield 13499 is what we
bought it for H that's only a 30k in
profit but uh we do what we can okay we
got all the cult necklaces sold or
bought
sorry another one sold and yeah we'll
pop those off for 712 I guess okay 35
[Music]
and we'll try buying four of these to
start with and yeah we got cult
necklaces all sold so pretty nice on
those okay so now I think we're going to
filter down to some cheaper items again
I think the regen bracelet might be
decent to of fire I don't prly like you
oh we sold some wizard boots finally oh
and we got ton two zamai God swords
coming through
uh so we're going to pull that out cuz I
don't we Ry any more of
those and we're going to pop those in
for get those in quickly CU we want to
lock down that margin 20K on the regen
bracelet I guess
312k just try buying one of
those and we actually sold our brine
saber finally oh my god um and we bought
the regen bracelet pretty damn
quickly uh sell it
for
3143 okay now just update the rest of
the stuff we have have um dragon fire
Shield sold I think for a 35k margin got
another one sold and another one bought
I
guess and we're getting 15K on each one
so not too bad oh we sold that one
already but I mean we're going to be
only doing this for 20 minutes so we're
not so likely to get screwed so let's do
a Sears
ring uh Sears ring a crazy price now
720k uh 7
15K I'll do four of those toxic Trident
try buying it
for
2655 let's go for
one
26 yeah just go for
one okie dokie we got some stuff sold
but I think we're going to lower down
these regen bracelets cuz it might have
been a bit of a fluke that we sold them
for that quick and that
high okay so we have a Zam godsword sold
um if we're not buying them for this
then the margin must be pretty poo want
to get this dragon fire shield in as
quick as possible okay we sold the
dragon fire Shield
um kind of want to put an offer in for
more cuz it's not not going super
slowly okay so we got a dragon fire
Shield uh we're going to pop that in for
13 to 5K 13
325k and we also got the oh my God we
instantly sold it
what ah
crap I suck I really just need to
actually slow down and check my stuff
13499 actually well might lower that
down then we got a toxic Trident so we
bought it for
2655 and
uh 266
6 five not a huge margin on there so
we're probably not going to do that okay
so we got another dragon fire Shield
let's not screw this one up and we sold
the uh toxic Trident as well which is
nice oh my God guys it's sunny out I can
see the light oh my jeez it's actually
in my um Hometown it's actually had 28
days of rain out of the last 30 isn't
that [__] depressing okay we sold the
wizard boots back um I don't remember
what we bought them for I think that
still might be a profit though so that's
nice okay we sold a regen bracelet as
well uh we're down to 40 seconds left so
I know it's kind of nice to get those
two things sold at least um the regen
bracelet would have been better but
unfortunately we ended up just losing
well actually we probably broke even on
the item as a whole but um not worth the
trouble the dragon fire Shield would
have been better as well but um I think
we're going to lose a bit of money on
this particular flip but we got 15
seconds left by far the best item was
the first one I did the heavy
ballista quite nice got a 50k margin on
each one flip I'm assuming the buying
limit is worth at least and after that
we'll have to see H but yeah there we go
time limit is done let's get that thing
out of here so yeah we'll pull these out
and we're going to instant sell them and
just really hope that uh please don't
screw me over please don't screw me over
like last
time h no don't want to hit this for
that okay not too bad we
lost 35k on that not the worst in the
world okay that's the main main problem
there and we sold that
for pretty decent loss on that one okay
so let's see what we got from 1 hour of
flipping recommended items only uh let's
go right here okay so from doing the G
tracker recommended which actually
worked quite a bit better than I thought
uh we made about 700k um so definitely
pretty decent considering um these items
were some of the highest traded ones in
the expensive category u cmer k not bad
um definitely I've done better I've done
worse um but I'm considering the last
couple episodes I've gotten a lot of
money but quite a bit bit of that was
based on some serious luck um these ones
I hadn't checked the margin didn't
really do any research I was just kind
of poing them in there as I saw them and
we still managed to make 700k in 1 hour
so hope you guys enjoyed and I will see
you guys in the next episode
[Music]